[Applaudissements]
ainsi la pop et à vous la voyez un voile
à pau qui disait tout cancer ou coucou
salut popeye c'est tout elle a des
dossiers sur tout le monde même sur moi
l'étude paraît-il santos vous avez tous
regardé cette semaine encore
bien sûr cette semaine et l'espagne qui
arriveront voilà ça va ya du lourd
aujourd'hui
eh bien je voulais vous dire
félicitations civile pourquoi oui bah
parce que je sais pas ce que c'est grâce
à vous grâce à moi mais vos chroniqueurs
ont fini par vous écouter et oui
maintenant il pour prendre la parole il
est vraiment on a ça marche
alors du coup il faut de la patience en
fait pour eu leur faut beaucoup beaucoup
de pas s'il s'en va regarder si on
regarde pas il le fera jamais il ne fera
jamais allée girondine
moi je comprends
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
et apparemment pas un magazine ton très
vite un nom je vous jure que c'est vrai
il ya toujours moyen favoriser quelqu'un
épouse de temps de réponse de leur ex
été ravalé le top des sujets qui
n'intéressent pas les hommes
[Musique]
tout ça maintenant
ouais nombreux je ne peux pas donner la
parole à tous forcément vous savez quand
on est un gâteau un moment papineau
certaine la famille eh ben il faut
savoir on l'achetait produit le jour
comment vous préparer aux mineurs un
truc pendant une heure et après tu sais
tu la séquence a défilé la séquence
allait finir après ton mission alors
plus de maquettes aux messieurs alain
catoire insu un truc une heure on sait
que tu as encore chauffeur livreur est
encore libre et des ondes ou qu'est-ce
qui se bat et malgré tout les veaux que
vous leur mettez cyril et c'est même
plus des vents c'est carrément du
mistral
les bayonnais qui persiste à vouloir
prendre la parole c'est magnifique c'est
beau avoir mal d'espoirs cotisation
c'est aussi peut-être touché tombe
dessus des normes pression avec tout ce
qui est sorti ces derniers temps donc
forcément un moment où son peuple je
suis un câble ça arrive à des chanteurs
comme a dit mathieu ça arrive à des
animateurs
ça arrive à plein de gens et un moment
peut-être qu'il va dire lui-même ouais
là j'ai peut-être été trop loin gg j'ai
pété un câble
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
celle du jeudi et vous avez donc je les
connais beaucoup de gens qui disent
pourquoi doc gynéco népal en ce moment
alors je vous le dis il ya aucun
problème avec lui c'est doc gynéco est
en fête religieuse
voilà non mais si je vous dis c'est
l'effet du vent ce moment alors beinheim
et moi on fait les fait aussi mais lui
il est extrêmement religieux ça veut
dire je crois qu'ils y voient là il
prendra un petit voilà donc qu'il est
pas là il sera pas là non plus semaine
prochaine sachez que moi et valérie
bénaïm on sera pas là non plus mardi et
mercredi
voilà mais lui il sera de retour dès que
les fêtes juives seront terminés courant
mai juste après alors pour qu'il y ait
d'autres choses oui vous vous dicter vos
règles mais vous n'êtes pas le premier à
les suivre
vous êtes même le premier à prendre
quelques petites libertés hu a surtout
mis en terme de musique alors cyril
connaît presque les paroles
ben c'est parti je pose un regard de
quoi
[Musique]
soit deux vaisseaux a dit le mois d'août
que tu es jusqu'au pied de mât de
censure des dossiers kerouac et loire et
loire
ouais ouais de se voir le bateau le
bateau ou là où la gare
l'espagnol quand tu bouges caisse
épaules et je suis touché ça va sur les
questions quand tu danses
je suis tombé
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
c'est là où vous êtes complètement
centre dans la façon l eugénisme vous
fait peur quand vous voyez comme ça ne
pas du tout je suis hyper sympa mais
celui-là mais je sais pas vous avez là
habité quand même ya là plusieurs
habitants alors stéphane plaza ne m'a
jamais dit non non mais mais messi mais
ça n'est jamais nommé est ce que j'ai
tenté plusieurs personnes que personne
je suis content d'être là une
répartition ni même presque ah non voilà
j'ai un petit bonus si vous voulez oui
c'est le petit bonus en vo alors du coup
syrie prof d'espagnol
bah c'est cadeau
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
j'adore vraiment fou en fait c'est
pourquoi vous êtes nombreux dans votre
tête quand même j'avais chanté ma mère
n'est pas normal beau à voir en vrai
vraiment si vous êtes heureux d'être sur
ce plateau c'est vrai que génial
vraiment bien me fondre à man ouest ce
qui a vous êtes bien dans les livres
avance alors êtes vous avec l'hymne tout
pour autant d'antennes ce que vous
enchaînez source d'amour très
sérieusement il faut une énergie
incroyable vous l'a développé vous allez
tout en énergie avec magazine ou sur tf1
imagine qu'on fasse trois heures avant
un grand prime sera d'abord on l'aurait
jamais fait sur tf1
impossible alors mais tu es fan aurait
jamais osé nous mettre à l'animateur
avant et après impossible
[Rires]
il aurait voulu répéter pendant 4h 5h 6h
avec tous les lendemains vous dire je
n'ai pas du tout répéter c'est surtout
que c'est du direct
pat on aura bientôt plus rougir
justement zaza parce que cyril on sait
qu'il est seul dans son monde mais vous
aussi vous êtes seul dans votre monde
voit en fait vous n'avez besoin de
personne pour vous ambiancer un oeil
dans la série une salle trop ambiance
dans regarde tout ça il a à mes
partisans
[Musique]
kadima qu'on avait droit
r toutes les mains en l'air toutes les
marolles r
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
celui-ci
[Musique]
je suis soir
elle est pourtant bien là ça fait
plaisir
oui tous contents d'être là alors il ya
des questions également à ce soir les
cherry pour qui on a une première
question c'est quoi oui on a une
question de nate henn pour vous cyril
c'est une question vidéo 1 à thann
balancier mal en six parties saluent
baba donc voilà c'était juste pour
savoir autour de la table c'était
quelques chroniqueurs en quiche au havre
et le mans confiance alors il n'est pas
là ce soir c'est matthieu delormeau vous
transporte beaucoup c'est qu'il - le -
rohff la fouine est évidemment de
l'ormeau vous aurez match et oui jean
michel
je maximum et c'est pas ce qu'il va dire
que je vais dire où vous pourrez en
dessous ça veut dire de leur mort
évidemment o'kelly moi je dirais non
ah oui moi je me fais pas du tout
confiance à la raison pardon nouveau
mathieu ça me gêne pas d'accord de leurs
mots parce que c'est facile à dire à
dieu ça fait partie du jeu et vous
répond mathieu merci le relais quand
même
ouais c'est le contraire de darty alors
on a d'autres où la question question ou
vidéo ou pas qu'est ce que tu veux ok
d'accord si je fais ce que je veux alors
une petite vidéo on part sur titi
parisien 444 c'est qui ça bien c'est un
fan 12 qui pose une question
alors certains tweets excusez moi isast
et ton anniversaire il ya quelques jours
à tuer reçu des cadeaux de la part de
tes amis chroniqueur chez font-ils tout
ce qui prouvera d'un jeu allez on va
passer avec étions très embarrassant
alors vous pas encore pas encore annoncé
l'armure alors l'ennemi
ok on accroît comme au dossier on est
dessus sur mathieu c'est dommage qu'il
soit pas là lorsqu'il a trouvé de quoi
se recycler à au cas où ça se passe mal
sur cette saison pour le oui et oui le
coaching en développement personnel
j'aime bien me faire je vote pour vous
syrie n'est pas vous êtes carrément
réceptif à tout ça j'adore on a des
images sur des résultats sur la toile a
pris beaucoup d'énergie et métaphores ce
cirque a pas une fin mais celle de
l'audit aurait agi de change ton jeu tu
montes sur duke est un peu mou les ondes
et à des machins pas en fait si tu fais
bien tout petit peu tout était la
locomotive et les wagons
[Musique]
je m'attendais à me faire chier ces
magouilles s'appelait encore bas vous
laissez faire quand même
il est out ils écoutent ce que je sais
c'est que je ne me coûte mais non je ne
sais même pas ce qui me dit je sais
qu'ils me saoule
voilà c'est tout parfois ça peut être à
mon conseil non aux allées balkans mais
las pour lui parler on a on n'a pas
d'autre chose y en a qui est vraiment
pas prêt à recevoir les conseils de
battue c'est eric naulleau awadi donc il
a terminé zemmour et balaye le termine
aussi aux lois le terminator il va tous
à sa mère
[Musique]
non
c'est un empire
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
mais moi ce que j'aime dans cette
émission aujourd'hui que c'est vrai
c'est matthieu delormeau eric naulleau
qui sont réunis et je crois qu'elle est
ainsi plus facile sokhiev dos ça c'est
ça qui est beau c'est pure c'est sa
deuxième dans touche pas aux poches
bonjour ce boulot il est temps qu'on n'a
pas une recrue comme celle ci il est
exceptionnel eric naulleau vraiment
j'aime fort et mathieu bien sûr aussi
messi réprimer ces échanges la sécu avec
je pensais qu'il était peut-être un
potin qui n'est pas du navire ont un peu
d'eau en fait un super super sympa il
vient vers nous il résulte de tout ce
passait tout son temps avec toi
incroyable il est géré en compte mais
bien surpris il avait un peu peur c'est
vrai alors les chéris chaque jeudi
maintenant on va continuer vidéo dans un
instant millions il y aura également eu
aussi la question qui pue c'est la
question à laquelle personne ne veut
répondre je ne la connais pas même moi
même on va tirer les mois c'est pas
disproportionnée
[Applaudissements]
magaye jouer sa place c'est maintenant
mon frère j'ai tous les chroniqueurs et
si je suis dans je ne sais pas quelle
est la question
je m'étire aux sorties un tir au sort a
bataillé les couleurs innocente un noir
et d'aïn benian innocenti médaille mais
nos sentiers et oui les mecs se sont
battus pour ses bons à la connais marc
laboulle assez vous aurez pour vous
montrer alors je vais prendre cela pour
montrer à bas regarder ça là c'était
celle qu'il fallait pas regarder
cyril hanouna préparer un match n'est
pas mince voilà donc les samoa c'est sûr
que c'est pas moi celle ci pour jean
michel maire jean-michel arrière maillot
pas donc j'ai pas la réponse
ban en mai mais c'est pas une question
de culture générale
[Applaudissements]
c'est la question à laquelle personne ne
me répond c'est la question qui pue
c'est une tannée quoi c'est parti
afficher la carte occupe une place et
les chroniqueurs dû plus jouer au moins
doué au lit
selon votre intuition ou vos à vendre ça
tombe bien sûr vont très vite à les
louer aux moins doués bas à gauche mais
je me limite où tu donc moi le plus doué
après je mettrais jean isnard ainsi qu'à
son jeu en trois carrières ex aequo avec
benjamin et que les hommes
non non oui oui que les sommes que des
hommes peuvent vraiment je t'ai pas dit
non non raymond second parent et maxime
bah évidemment on classera bien venir
jusqu'au bout tout ça est plutôt sympa
on a d'autres choses wap ou qui bonsoir
oui on a d'autres choses ma chérie bien
sûr en fait travailler avec vous c'est
un pur bonheur je le découvre là ça fait
à peine trois semaines
c'est vraiment bien si vous êtes
vachement les courtes où vous êtes
disponible oui ça c'est un régal
c'est vrai quoi je suis pas bon et
surtout pour les équipes qui sont
derrière ces merveilleuses l'analyse
d'études dans l'autobus aucune mais je
ne m'abuse
ça va
[Musique]
bull annonce oulata ben gaudin allait ou
la moue lagarde aurait dû garder ça
[Applaudissements]
la finale a mis deux heures à l'opéra
sera rien on a vu soraya ma chérie bien
sûr voilà qu essayer de me coiffer c'est
à hem et parce que je vis la musique
je prie l'abri même taille que le monde
vous entoure vous êtes dans votre truc
ça va je suis dans ma bulle way
oui oui j'ai pas compris le projet
cravate mais bon c'est pas grave moi
c'était pas mal non et vous pourvu faut
poser le temps car la guerre folle alors
oui elle je voulais vous parler vous
souvenez du film le premier film qui ont
diffusé sur canal le samedi je l'envié
samedi du mois qu'est ce que vous en
souvenez oui bien sûr ben moi j'ai pas
de décodeur dommage mais en fait j'ai
envie de vous parler des images que
quand tu as le son ça va mais si t'as
pas les images et que tu as juste le son
et bat un petit peu l'impression trop de
deux séquences arbres et pourtant des
dents tmp mais je vous propose la petite
minute at badiane
et voici dans la face à metz je crois
qu'en même temps celle et les matches
tous les jours c'est bull sont bien
placés on n'avait pas repris assez
sérieux
mais les meilleurs quand c'est long tous
les jours vingt salade niçoise et boboul
vous les connaissez vraiment et voilà
c'est fou parce que bienvenus la
subtilité double écran
la coi le double sens merci de sept
membres et un mot une idée exactement où
ils dénient magic vient très belle
rentrée
ah oui je me disais ce matin en réunion
a besoin d'anti un frein en fait une
très bonne rentrée mais des classes non
c'est vrai que maxime fait une très
belle entrée il est très sympathique
oui avec les têtes qui arrive vous êtes
vous êtes un grand amoureux en fait tout
est bordé d'amour surtout pour les
invités savent choisir
oui vous vous donner de l'amour de la
générosité aux abois t c'est pour ça
qu'ils viennent avec plaisir ici niveau
créativité il ya encore du taf on va pas
se mentir
olam est bien là mais bien en gage merci
bonjour merci merci
[Musique]
merci merci maison jérusalem les états
doivent encore devant d'away we die
gaubert donc beaucoup de grands lacs le
terreau d'amour endroit exact de la nuit
de toutes les stars c'est tout le monde
tous les invités on les connaissait très
bien ici comme vous un non mais c'est
vrai vous connaissez je sais pas ce que
vous faites de ce soir vous avez une vie
de people à céret vous avez incarné
adresse il avait en tant que telle et
c'est normal de maquereaux au bout
d'eux-mêmes emprunté par contre vous
vous allez avoir 20 ans de taule encore
des petites choses
oui aurait sur les câlins et l'amour je
vais me faire un coeur avec les doigts
cyril nature or c'est joli c'est mignon
on va rester sur la mignonneries à cette
semaine c'est maxime ganic il une offre
qui nous l'offre pardon et wii prend
soin la génération des générations du
dessus on a l'impression qu'en fait il
veut juste se plate est placé sur
l'héritage a on va regarder n'en voit ça
on regarde tu es arrivée isabel à
l'émission seront actifs de ce week-end
un candidat s'est planté en fait
prestation
soprano c'est un titan envoyée laplaud
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
l'union nationale
ce maxi les empires allez une petite
dernière la série oui on va parler de
kelly kelly vous avez un talent qu'il y
un talent qui parfois vous ferez mieux
de rester caché
et oui le slam ça vous parle sans lui
qu'il dise la meuse alors par contre
quand maxime gagné sans bel et bien ça
devient un gros moment de gêne ans mais
moi on a les images des leçons
malheureusement
rien de nouveau
dormir dormir
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
ces trucs sur kelly parce que je crois
qu'elle avait un problème dernièrement
6,6 week end on le sait que kelly elle
adore débattre surtout pendant les
pauses pub c'est les mêmes choses
intéressantes à dire et très peu de
temps pour pour le pour débattre donc du
coup je propose la séquence on s'en fout
avec kelly b 2010
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
le gagnant de transformer
[Applaudissements]
merci pour lui voilà